advisers to president trump's tell cbs
news the president
is increasingly aware his lawsuits will
not change the election results
however according to these sources he
wants to be seen as a fighter so the
campaign will keep fighting in the
courts
deborah alfarone has the latest from
capitol hill
cbs news has called arizona for
president-elect joe biden
the win puts mr biden at 290 electoral
college votes
further cementing his win
president-elect biden's new chief of
staff
ron klain told msnbc that the trump
administration's blocking of transition
efforts
is hurting their ability to combat the
coronavirus pandemic
the sooner we can get our transition
experts
into meetings with the folks who are
planning that vaccination campaign
the more seamless the transition from a
biden presidency to a trump presidency
can be
the president is receiving a briefing on
operation warp speed
the plan to distribute covid vaccines
nationwide
right now there are officials inside the
department of health and human services
who are busy planning a vaccination
campaign for the months of february and
march
when joe biden will be president only
four republican senators have
acknowledged president-elect biden's win
but even some of the president's
strongest allies are now saying that mr
biden
should receive intelligence briefings we
should be in the same posture that we
ran throughout the whole campaign with
both of them receiving briefings
as they're both trying to be able to
prepare china is the latest nation to
reach out to mr biden to congratulate
him on his victory
but foreign nations are having to set up
these calls without the assistance of
the state department
a lot of these world leaders know how to
reach him he is speaking to them
they are congratulating him on his
election as president
meanwhile president trump is tweeting
conspiracy theories about voting
machines changing votes
but the government agency in charge of
election security refuted that
saying there is no evidence that any
voting system deleted or lost
votes changed votes or was in any way
compromised
deborah alferon cbs news washington
president trump is expected to provide
an update on operation warp speed with
the corona virus this afternoon at one
in about an hour
from the white house we'll have live
coverage on air and online at eight
newsnow dot com